At any point in time, we’re continuously
being encouraged to pick up some novel or
other. Reviews, the recommendations of friends
and the windows of bookstores edge us towards
certain titles that, we’re promised, will
definitively answer the deepest needs that
we bring to literature. Imagine that we have
picked up some such title. It’s late in
the evening and we’re just starting out,
our volume releasing the characteristic sweet
smell of newly opened work. The author is
going to great lengths to get us interested
in the life of someone living in Edinburgh
in the 1930s; it’s raining a lot and their
car breaks down; they’ve got a friend in
Budapest who is pregnant; there’s a robbery
at a department store. There’s a reference
to Dundas Street and we flick back thirty
pages and realise that’s where the main
character’s sister used to live. There’s
a retired engineer with very bushy eyebrows
who must be important in some way we don’t
know yet. Immense effort and intelligence
are being devoted to exploring the existence
of a fictional individual. But at this point,
an incidental yet rather major thought strikes
us: no one, we realise, has ever looked at
our life – our habits, our friends, our
past, our dilemmas and problems – with such
sustained curiosity or in such detail. In
the novel on our lap, there seem to be plenty
of pithy insights, clever summations, striking
observations and astute analyses, but all
for the sake of the workings of the mind of
someone else, who’s not really very much
like us. It’s a familiar situation we’ve
been educated politely to take for granted.
But now it hits us with particular force:
we’re reading the wrong book. What we should
really be doing is reading a book about us
– written with the same elegance and wisdom,
but placing the raw material of our life in
a lucid order, selecting and joining up diverse
events in our chaotic stream of consciousness
and turning them into a coherent story. We’re
politely interested in the stories of others,
but the story we really need to hear about
is our own. What we really crave is for someone
to make loving sense of us. We want them to
write us, with all our complexity and obscurity,
down in crisply phrased and clear sentences.
Our reading of someone else’s novel is dutiful
and well-educated no doubt, but it is as if
we went to the doctor and they made a very
accurate diagnosis of someone else’s earache,
or if a financial advisor went to great lengths
to present us with a solution to the money
troubles of a stranger, from which we could
at best extract the occasional fleeting hint
of what might possibly be useful in our own
case. In the 1690s, one of the greatest of
French writers, François Fénelon, was appointed
tutor to the young Duke of Burgundy. To assist
with his education, Fénelon wrote a long
and fascinating novel called The Adventures
of Telemachus in which the Duke, lightly disguised,
was the central character. The problems the
character in the novel faces were exactly
the problems the Duke was actually facing;
the strengths and weakness of the central
character – carefully understood by the
writer – were his. It sounded like the rarest
and most cultivated luxury to have someone
write a novel about you. But it is a treat
we should all be granted – and perhaps secretly
crave. We don’t need to give up our jobs
and become writers – because this book of
ourselves is one we’re writing already;
we’re at work on it in the early hours,
when we can’t sleep, when we daydream, make
plans, go over the past – and give ourselves
over to retelling, as best we can, what has
really happened to us and what it all could
mean. It’s simply a pity we don’t devote
as much energy as we should to this emerging,
critically important work. It is hugely noble
that we spend so much time reading the novels
of others. It is life-saving and properly
generous to ourselves when we learn to order
and make sense of the experiences of our own
troubled days and nights. There is no risk
in reading plenty of novels, but on a regular
basis, we should carve the time to write and
then read back to ourselves the nascent, unfolding novel of
the story of our own lives.
To learn more about Self-Knowledge, click the link on your screen now.